my three core values in life
comment yours below
core values are extremely important
because they allow us to use them
when making decisions
if something aligns with our core values
you should make that decision
and if not do not make that decision
No.1 freedom
freedom of my time to do what I want
when I want with who I want
is my ultimate north star
No.2 experiences
I used to thought I wanted a big house
the fancy car
but now I realize I want to do things
I want to live whenever I die
when a mindful of memories
not a house full of possessions
No.3 adventure
the house with white picket fence
life is not for me
the world is a big place
and I plan on seeing a lot of it